there is no hope whatsoever our species
will be extinguished probably in a
couple of generations maybe even before
that depending upon the microbes the
microbes in the world and of course the
potential for nuclear war not to mention
as in my short story chick Shalhoub when
that comet comes back again so we're all
doomed everything sucks I have no good
news for anybody other authors want to
make their audience feel good I want
everybody to feel really bad just joking
I'm writing about the environment it
obsesses me our place as a species on
this planet we are animals and yet we're
something else too and how do those two
elements of us intersect and what does
it mean for this environment people say
save the earth well the earth as far as
we know will be here for another three
and a half billion years until of course
the Sun becomes a yellow giant and burns
us to a cinder like a charcoal briquette
but really what the environmentalists
are saying is let's save the planet
under the conditions that allowed our
species to arise well of course we're
not doing this if you remember in 2000 I
wrote a friend of the earth about global
warming well here we are so I wish I had
better news what what sustains me
mentally although after this interview
people may question whether I have been
sustained mentally his nature and my art
when I'm doing my art I am
revolving these questions in my mind I
don't begin with a political point I
just let it flow and see what it is and
secondly being in nature I'm in nature a
lot within the week ago I was in the
High Sierras
every day by myself sitting by a creek
deep in the woods just
meditating on the good good things good
things like the joy of being an animal
in nature of smelling the breeze of
listening to the water of seeing the
various creatures that are coming by you
know there's a lot of wildlife in the
Sierra Nevada I go out every day and I
see things like ants and biting flies
one of the problems with a novelist
trying to take the facts of real life
and meditate on them and make a fiction
is that because of the internet we have
instant access to everything all the
time and all information so a lot of the
Bazaar and news stories that I would
meditate on and write about particularly
for short stories in the beginning of my
career where we're known only to me
they were my stories now everybody knows
these stories immediately and they're
all writing there they're things about
it so it is it's it's difficult in the
information age to find your own little
story but so far I think I've been able
to do it for instance The New Yorker
will shortly publish a new story of mine
from this collection I was telling you
about and it's called are we not men and
it's about CRISPR technology which
obsessively you know this is a gene
editing technology which makes it much
easier to edit genes in other species in
fact if you subscribe to nature and
science as I do for oh the past year
there's a huge ad right in the beginning
of a boxing glove on a fist and it says
knockout any gene they're selling kits
to amateurs to anybody to play with
various bacteria and gene in it
these bacteria is this a good idea I
don't think so and of course in my
telling we're just projecting slightly
into the future when we can make new
species not to mention the parent who
wants to get his kid into the best
school
give me a break I mean it'll be
like buying a new car when you have a
kid you know you go you see how the
jeans line up and you pick whatever you
want you want an eight-foot-tall you
want orange eyes you want somebody can
run the hundred yard dash in nine
seconds that's what it's coming to so
we're not going to be humans anymore
which I guess is no no no great loss you
know I don't think that politics and art
mix if you have a political point to get
across I'll give a speech right now say
but art is supposed to be a seduction
and you invite in this case a reader in
as your equal to to make the same
discoveries that you make so I don't
know what any story or novel will be it
just happens and evolves and as it does
of course I'm seeing what it means
thematically I'm seeing how the
characters develop and so on I mean
there is an element of controlling mind
but 90% of what I'm doing in the
unconscious state is just happening the
joy of it is in the doing of course
because it gives you something to do
every day in life rather than just look
at the wall and contemplate suicide so
that's very rewarding the most rewarding
moment is when you see it come together
and you finish any project whether it's
a short story or a novel it is an
exhilaration or rush a tremendous rush
of exhilaration which lasts for maybe
half a day and then you face the fact
that you're completely bankrupt of ideas
worthless you'll never write again and
then you have to worry about writing the
next one for me it's a kind of iron
discipline and a routine daily the same
thing over and over I have recently
begun to use Twitter as a kind of
performance space and the performance is
this here you have entree to the
glamorous life of an international
literary celebrity Wow
but really it's a stick and the stick is
I'm a schmuck like anybody else
so the first selfie I ever took
for instance I was showing the tweets
there's me cleaning the muck out of the
pond and I had two beautiful buckets of
black muck and I leaned over to
photograph them but I realized wait a
minute my face is showing in the muck so
I took a muck selfie so what I'm I'm
having fun I'm joking I pick a picture
make a quip of course but this is my
daily life and I think underneath it all
is a serious intent and that is my
routine I need it so desperately so I
showed them I love a stick also I show
them the same thing every day the same
street scene in the morning and the same
blank screen and then they talk about
what I'm working on and then the screen
goes blank for a while because I'm
working so I do kind of emphasize that
particularly with a long project you
have to stay at it and it doesn't always
go well but you have to fight through
all of those bad moments I always by the
way keep a loaded 357 Magnum pistol
right next to me on the desk in case it
doesn't go well that's a more good
advice I think for for beginning writers
plus it cuts down the surplus population
writer's block is the kind of thing that
does make you use that gun or at the
very least you wind up wrapped in chains
in the sub-basement in the mental
hospital you can't go there yes of
course I have periods in which it's not
working but I tried to work through it I
just delivered a new book of short
stories to my publisher for next year
and I was drumming myself up to start
doing this in January after I delivered
the Tara notes last fall and it just
couldn't come up with anything you know
it just wasn't working and it took me a
while until finally the first story
began to come and was so hard and I read
it over and over but then a little
period blossom that I wound up writing
the seven that I needed to complete the
collection until very recently when I'm
now starting to do research
for your novel so yes you do have
periods when you're not inspired but you
know if you're an artist
all you want to do is make art so that's
a tremendous motivating factor I mean I
do you know occasionally make love to my
wife and once in a while have a nice
meal you know clean up the house take
the dog for a walk
but basically you know I'm living in
order to make art